[Music]  where's the sample Volkov isn't a good  man disappoint your friends sold some  diamonds my diamonds fix high quality  it's not real the best I've ever seen  but no the friends that you have now  they're cheating you this is a problem I  assume one of many your responsibility  was to procure the sample a single  diamond  now before it's too late you're in some  sort of trouble I think if I can just  draw on your patience patience mr. Hill  he's like here in a silver all no matter  how I should start with eventually  you'll run out  come on in let's do business the dams  good  hey bu you swear loyalty by becoming  blood brothers  so if we're not brothers maybe we're not  friends either  you